Luke is on the Falcon Luke is on the
Falcon Luke is on the Falcon Lucas on
the Falcon Lucas on the fact I'm having
a breakdown
Lucas on the Millennium Falcon last
night I was watching Game seven of the
World Series it was a nail-biter just
kidding blew us out of the water and I
was really stressing out and kind of
having a bad time but then out of
nowhere during a commercial break
Star Wars the last Jedi just casually
drops a new TV spot without warning now
normally TV spots you know they give us
a few new shots and it's kind of like
okay this was cool but no this one
offered things we haven't seen before
like Luke on the Millennium Falcon huh
let's break it down okay so Luke steps
onto the Millennium Falcon for the first
time in forever
obviously Rey drove the Falcon there
with Chewie so he's gonna reunite with
Chewie on octo but there's a lot he
doesn't know like does he know but Han
died gonna ask Chewbacca
we're Honus or or maybe he steps onto
the Falcon and then kind of has this
feeling and then he knows but oh the
memories on the Falcon cue montage
everybody
okay so obviously that was like the
biggest takeaway from the trailer I
screamed my frickin head off but we also
get a look at some new stuff like smokes
fancy new palace he's really good at
interior design so it's flanked by those
Praetorian guards which I'm really
hoping we get to see actually fight
someone because that would be awesome
we got a little Huck c-stand in there
you know whatever but the dialogue here
zones are saying we get darkness rises
and like to meet it honestly in my
opinion this sounds like it's coming
from three different chopped up lines
darkness rises and light to meet it but
I'm sitting here like Charlie day trying
to figure out what this could possibly
mean then we get a little more Finn
little wahoo
a little scream on crate driving that
resistance ski speeder lululu little ol
Lando and then we got more Leia of
course
and then this shot of the Falcon
escaping what I assume are those caves
and crate that we've seen before who's
driving the Falcon is the Luke is it ray
is it Chewie is that the pork gonna be
him gonna be him
let me get this interesting moment
between ray and Luke where he's like
this isn't gonna go the way you think it
is and then she raises her lightsaber
kind of implying that she's kind of like
strike him down and betray Luke and go
off with kylo and join the dark side and
like maybe she does for a second I mean
in the last Jedi trailer I really
thought I that was a misdirect that was
a complete mr. act there's no way that
she's talking to kylo Ren in that scene
there's like embers falling behind him
the light source is different she's
clearly sitting by like a campfire or
something but this scene it's raining
it's the same lighting it's definitely
the same scene but somebody pointed out
on Twitter hey this scene kind of looks
like it's in Reverse because if you look
at her second hand that's holding the
lightsaber it's like who does this I
don't know I mean I guess I made it look
natural but it looks like it's in
Reverse go ahead and look at it her hand
her second hand kind of looks like it's
in Reverse but yeah ray doesn't know a
lot about the pork what are you doing
buddy ray doesn't know a lot about the
force at all so it is possible that she
doesn't know which way to go and may go
with kylo Ren or may go to snow
or may go with somebody for a hot minute
because Luke doesn't want to train her I
don't think she's kind of like ignite
her lightsaber and kill him or anything
like that but I do think that's the same
scene so that's an interesting
interesting thing but the craziest thing
of all is that we cut so much
information out of a 45-second TV spot
that came out of nowhere was so
unexpected
uh you guys leave in the comments below
if you think
listen if one of them had to go to the
dark side Luke array who do you think it
would be I don't think it's gonna be
either of them but if you had to pick
one who would you pick and let me know
what kind of videos you guys would like
to see going forward you want more Star
Wars videos doing videos about something
else do you want just all porks all the
time a 24-hour report Network let me
know in the comments or you can always
tweet me at ash Crossin I tweet way too
much thank you guys so much for watching
I'll catch you next time